what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we are covering Green Arrow
rebirth which is actually Italian we
haven't covered green arrow for a while
mostly because I kind of lost interest
in the stories I like the idea of green
arrow and black Canary getting back
together and there were a couple stories
that were pretty good but for the most
part I've kind of dropped off but this
one picks up in the aftermath of heroes
in crisis so it's more like a heroes in
crisis tie in but it is a pretty cool
pretty cool story because this really
deals with the death of Roy Harper now
when it comes to Roy Harper's funeral
you guys will actually notice it's
pretty small it's not a very very big
funeral right this is not like the death
of Superman worse like this worldwide
celebrated superhero has passed on and
this is designed to happen for a couple
different reasons the first is because
Roy Harper was never a huge superhero he
was never on the level of like Batman
Superman Wonder Woman or anything like
that which is something Oliver Queen's
gonna hit on here in a second but the
other reason is because it's more
private and it's more closed off and the
location itself is symbolic now for
those of you guys who are very familiar
with Roy Harper's history you guys
understand why this is so important but
with regards to this little tidbit here
you have Oliver Queen it really just
kind of muses to himself and talked
about maybe it's a dream maybe one of
it's true
some of the people who were here don't
feel like they should be here different
things like that you've got like you've
got Diana you've got Wonder Woman who
shows up and she starts talking to them
and so on but Oliver Queen himself
really begins to look at some
introspection and ask the question was
he really as good of a really as like a
father figure for a Roy Harper as he
should have been because it becomes a
point when Roy Harper just before he
went to sanctuary had come to Oliver
Queen and talked to him about what was
going on basically saying look he was
going to seek help and Oliver Queen
essentially blew him off and said look
he's got other things to worry about and
didn't give Roy Harper the time he
needed which means that Roy Harper was
for the most part sulking and basically
dealing in loneliness and that's a very
rough place to be because for Oliver he
looks back at Roy and says he wasn't as
good of a father figure as he should
have been you know he was more of a
mentor which he actually hits on again
here in a second and so really Oliver
Queen begins to lash out because when he
starts to talk about the notion of
sanctuary his argument here is Roy
Harper went to sanctuary to find help
what he found was death and instead of
the various members of the Justice
League saying were the ones at fault
they're like well we don't know who did
this we're trying to figure it out
Oliver Queen loses it and actually goes
to attach Superman now it's a great
moment here because we know that under
normal circumstances Oliver Queen never
would have went to pull this off but the
other half of this is this was so
dangerous about Oliver he could he could
basically turn the world of Superman
upside down but he could literally just
broadcast
to the world hey everyone Clark hints
actually Superman don't believe me take
his glasses off and watch what happens
and then realize how stupid you guys are
because you didn't realize that Superman
puts on glasses and suddenly he's a
whole different guy now because I get to
you guys right now I can't take my
glasses off you guys would be like yep
that's how much explain like I know him
because of his face and his voice and
everything the glasses don't change that
like these small things but you end up
having really everybody kind of jumping
in the way and basically telling Oliver
it's not their fault but Oliver doesn't
care and the reason why is because
Oliver is looking to transition blame
that's really what's going on here
Oliver Queen's guilt written by the
death of Roy Harper he's guilt-ridden by
the fact that a person that he met in
his younger years who we took under his
wing as a mentor ultimately perished
when he was seeking help and Oliver
Queen didn't give him the kind of help
that he needed
Oliver's looking over every single
mistake he ever made every choice he
ever made every decision that was made
with regards to Roy Harper and then
realizing that he didn't do everything
he could have and the result is that now
that way Harper is dead there's no way
to make up for that there's no way to
compensate for that in to finally find a
way to bring that back there's no way to
make that happen and so where he begins
to sort of tear into Superman and say
this is your fault you know he came to
you guys for help he came to you guys
for aid and instead you got him killed
Batman's not here he's out looking for
everybody's killer why are you guys
looking for the killer it's one of these
things where he just kind of lashes out
in every direction just Spears every
ounce of pain and anguish that he feels
in every single direction because the
truth of the matter is that Oliver
Queen's hurting like he's lost the
closest person needs to known to her
brother and he's just taking it out on
everybody and so in return ourian's up
having Martian Manhunter basically whisk
him away telepathically and mashin a
Martian Manhunter begin speaking truth
to reason and basically saying look this
is not the fault of anybody here it's
not Batman's fault it's not Superman's
fault it's not Wonder Woman's fault it's
none of their faults they're all here
grieving just like you are so let them
grief let them deal with the loss of
their friend and as in us a very
touching moment in a very important
moment here because it's just Oliver
Queen suffering and anguish and how many
of us have been in a situation like this
with us all we want to do is lash out
and be angry and scream and shout and
stomp our feet and say it's not fair
though like how many of us have been in
that situation and how many of us want
to respond accordingly but you have to
be able to understand that everybody's
coming to this from a different
perspective and so the result here is
that you end up having Donna Troy who
basically steps up and she begins really
telling her story
oi that the two of them were friends the
two of them were people who work
together the indication was that they
were basically lovers I don't know if
they ever really were or not but they
were two they were basically partners
and that he would go to the limits in
order to make sure that she was safe to
do whatever he needed to do and were to
make sure that his teammates always came
back and it's kind of a funny thing
because what she says is that while all
this was happening while worried Harper
was fighting on the Titans while Roy
Harper was doing the best he could to be
the best teammate he could he was also
fighting his own demons and that's kind
of the saddest thing about this and
that's what really stings when it comes
to Oliver Queen the most is that Roy
Harper was fighting his own demons and
Oliver Queen wasn't helping him and
that's what really seems to crush his
character so much is because he would he
became just as much of a burden even if
not a burden
certainly no measure of an aid for Roy
Harper as he did you know as you know
Roy Harper's own problems and so it's
it's interesting here because he goes to
sit down and runs across a woman who's
basically named Annie and the idea was
that she was an addict just like oh just
like where Harper was because of course
you know Roy Harper was a was a heroin
addict but she was an addict just like
where Harper was and the result is that
you know Roy Harper basically and you'll
help her to get clean and that's what we
end up learning the reason why this
location was chosen for the funeral had
nothing to do with anything being
arbitrary it was because this is where
Harper basically chose to become sober
it's where he chose to clean his life up
and move away from drug use and so it's
a very symbolic and a very important
place to him and it's one of the things
that basically added that that's really
the most important aspect of his life
and so talking with Black Canary
Oliver continues to kind of muse to
himself and say look I was not the kind
of person that way Harper needed me to
be and he thinks back to the old Green
Lantern Green Arrow stories you know
that the snowbirds don't fly when what
Harper has suddenly vanished and if you
in front of the guys you never read that
story where Harper disappeared the idea
was like what happened to Roy like what
happened to red arrow is he gone or I
guess speedy back then but like is he
gone is this somebody take him that's
the kind of thing that was rolling
through the story and rolling through
the mind of Oliver Queen while Green
Lantern was trying to help him
ultimately they basically found him in
like a back alley
shooting up heroin and so like with with
that going on Oliver lashed out he
completely freaked out on Roy instead of
asking the question but why are you
doing this though like why would you do
something like this and so what he did
is he looked back and he realized that
what Roy needed was a father figure he
didn't really need a mentor him he
needed a mentor but what he needed was
someone to be his father someone to
guide him throughout all facets of life
not someone to party with not someone to
run amok in and fight
you know various villains with not
someone to train him with someone to
always be there to put his hand on his
shoulder in say no matter what happens I
will always be here for you
that's what way Harper needed and that's
what Oliver never gave him and that's
what's so crushing form is because he
knew what he should have done but he
never did it the entire time and so for
him it's a devastating experience
because you end up having everybody
basically planting tree kits on their
own their own objects in order to help
him and you know help Roy pass on to the
next life but Oliver Queen's just kind
of left is the last man standing he's a
last man there and he just kind of
thinks over everything that happens he
thinks over everything that's gone on
he thinks over all the choices that he's
ever made with all with uh with with
Roy's character and it constantly comes
back to the same thing and a time when
Roy needed him the most in a time when
Roy needed his help and a time when Roy
I needed someone to talk to
when Roy needed someone to reach out to
Oliver Queen wasn't there he was off
fighting supervillains neo dealers Black
Canary all that kind of good stuff and
never once did he really tend to the
kind of things that Roy Harper needed
but that's kind of the interesting thing
about this is because it really is
Oliver Queen being unnecessarily hard on
himself because we could argue that if
we're Harper was really here where
Harper would just say you did the best
you could and that's all anybody ever
can do the best they can do that's all
you can ever ask for we do the best we
can with the circumstances we have and
the experience wisdom and knowledge we
have at the time and that's it that's
all anybody can ever ask for so it's a
pretty cool moment it's a pretty cool
little segment here and it's definitely
a beautifully written story but with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you are new here
too comments explained make sure you
guys at the sub button to become part of
the Rob core if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and I
will catch you all later peace
[Music]